Hey traders, it's Mike here, and I'm
shooting this quick video right ahead of
the cash open
on Thursday the 28th of May.
Just want to talk about the order flow
exhaustion entry model real quick. You
know, just to clarify the settings that
I went over yesterday cuz I did have a
conversation with a trader yesterday.
Just wanted to talk a little bit more
about the settings, why I use a swing
period of 25 as you can see right here.
And where is it here? Exhaustion.
Using the swing filter with exhaustion
print volume limit of 10. People say,
well, why not nine? I used to use nine.
I sort of expanded it out to 10
probably about a couple years ago.
Difference is obviously is just one
contract. I just wanted, you know, maybe
a few more trades to come in. And with
the swing filter going back 25 bars,
meaning it's got to be a higher high or
lower low over the last 25 bars with the
exhaustion print as well as price
action. That's something that I that I
haven't really discussed is it has to be
you know, it's a reversal sign. So,
after a reversal after the move, there
has to be, you know, for a reversal down
for a bearish signal to come in, it has
to be a red bar. For a bullish signal,
it would have to be
a green bar. So, just really quick, um
you know, we we got this one signal just
came in right ahead of the cash open.
It's about 8:15, cash is about to open
up pretty soon. It's about 8:28, 8:29.
Um you know, it just sort of went
sideways, came down here, ticked you
out. I never
tell traders to to to take trades right
ahead of the cash open. I think it's a
bad time to do it. You're better off
just waiting till the cash open. You
know, that being said, um overnight,
there was there was some nice trades
actually in the S&P's. Not many, but you
can see here
um
where are we here? Just go back a bit.
Um
There was this nice short signal right
here. This came about
4:55 in the morning.
All right, so we got the move up.
We got the reversal signal, right? For a
reversal signal, it has to be a red bar.
You're not looking at a green bar's high
up here of one, okay?
How are you going to get short off a
green bar, right? And market's still
going up. What you're looking for is the
red bar
here with the exhaustion print at a high
over you know, the the last X amount of
bars. I used 25. And this was a nice a
nice signal here. You can see it came
in.
Um
All right, and and we sold off. This is
from more or less,
you know, around the 30
32 31 and 1/2 area. Got all the way down
to
the hell here or 20s. That was a nice
10-point move in the morning. Um I think
there was uh one other that came in
during uh Asian hours. Let me just find
it here.
Okay, this one failed right here. Okay,
that's fine. You know, this one you got
a tight stop, right? You're just talking
about uh four points, but you get short
here. I mean, it just looked like it was
going to go, right? You got big
aggressive selling four, you got stacked
selling a balance of three. I'm sorry,
of four price levels and another two
down here and it just reversed and went
up. This one was no trade because we
didn't go lower
than the low of the signal bar. But, I
think there was a buy here. Let me just
make this up so you can see the
footprint a little bit better. Yeah,
right down here.
Okay. Up to where we had that sell
signal. So, this came in just around uh
just after midnight last night.
Here's your reversal signal, right?
You've got
the exhaustion print of eight. It's a
green bar at your swing low.
Um you know, coming into this low. You
know, granted it's around midnight, so
volumes are a little bit lighter. I
mean, these are small deltas, minus 13,
minus two, minus 61. Um then we see some
aggressive buying come in with a
positive delta. The next bar had minus
nine and again a small delta, but here's
your entry right here.
First bar didn't fire, second bar did.
Um and you're you know, getting short
around, you know, the 08 and 3/4 09
area. Trades all the way up into the 20s
where we just had that short that I was
telling you about that uh that you know,
you had the aggressive selling. Um but
this one failed and it it just stopped
you out. But again, you know, look at
that. You got a
you know, about a 15-point move here and
this trade, even though this trade
failed up here,
what's your risk, right? You're getting
short
here. You risk 1 2 3 4 5 ticks. You're
risking five ticks, just one point when
you just had a 15-point move.
Okay? Um nothing happened overnight in
the ultra bonds or since yesterday. Uh
we did have this low. This was uh it's
not exhaustion print, but it trade 15
there.
Um so it didn't fire cuz I used 10. And
I just really quick in the euro
currency, um
you had a couple here that failed.
But okay, so again, this is my
eight-range chart. So I got your
exhaustion print here, exhaustion print
here. Here's your entry. Here's your
entry. It failed.
Right? It just It started to go down
then came right back up, stopped you
out. This one again went down, sideways,
and then went up, would have stopped you
out.
Okay, you know,
that's you know, nobody likes to take
the loss, but
you're risking, you know, 10 ticks here,
but look at this one. Right off this
low, just uh after about 11:00 last
night,
this was a beautiful one. Here's your
exhaustion print nine here. You even got
this imbalance reversal of 94. It's a
selling imbalance in this green candle.
Um so we know that there's some
liquidity there acting as support and
this market went from about uh 115.99
you know, straight up to into the 20s
here. This is uh this area is what? 25.
20 to 25 right in here. Okay? I mean
I don't think you would have held it all
the way to this uh this signal here, but
you know, this is a good area to get
out. You know, again, that's 25 full
ticks, 50 half ticks.
All right? And again, you know, you lost
on this trade and there's that other
trade there. So, you lost, you know, 10
ticks here, 10 ticks there, but you made
50 ticks on this move.
All right? So, that was a nice trade.
And again, you know,
this is where people get a little or
tell me they're a little confused is
specifically on
you know, trying to figure out you know,
which ones to take. Well,
if it's a bullish signal,
right? It has to be going down.
You have to have the green bar with the
exhaustion print. You're not going to
have an exhaustion a bullish exhaustion
print like here
on the red bar with nine. Now, you're
not looking at that spot.
That's not where you look at. That's not
the area that you're looking at. On a
red candle, you're going to look at the
top offer side. On the green candle,
it's the bottom bid side.
All right? Just as um
Let me see if there's a
green candle here.
Uh whoops.
Ah,
>> [sighs]
>> what am I doing here with this drawing
tool?
Uh uh uh you'd be looking at So, if it
was a green candle, right? You're not
going to look and say, "Oh, I've got a
bearish exhaustion print here." No,
you wouldn't look for bearish signals in
a green candle. Right? You're going to
look at the bottom bid side. The 66
here, it's not an exhaustion print. 43,
it's not an exhaustion print.
Um
Now, here, right? People say, "What
about this one?" So, one, right? That's
an exhaustion print. That's the
lowest trade volume you can have in a
bar. Okay, it's a green candle.
It's the exhaustion print of one, but it
doesn't meet the criteria for the swing
filter cuz it's not a lowest low. Again,
I use 25. This is just, you know, over
the last 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 bars, 8 bars.
I want a clearer signal. If I were to
adjust my swing filter to like say five,
yeah, that would kick off just as this
one would kick off, but I use a much
stricter, higher level of 25
as my swing filter. Again, you can use
whatever you want, you know, 25, you can
use 30, you can use
50.
Um,
you know, 50 is is
is a lot. Uh, some people, you know, if
they trade minute-based charts, they
will use 30 because that's a half hour,
but obviously if you're on a range-based
chart, that sort of removes the time
aspect, it's the number of bars. All
right, so I hope that clarifies it a
bit. Um, thanks for watching this video
and I'll see you on the next one.